[Musique]
bonsoir en cette semaine de la nouvelle
année nous avons choisi de vous
restituer le climat de la guerre de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et par un BIA
extrêmement particulier c'est celui de
la radio Patrick oui alors on connaissaz
l'armée des ombres et ce soir on va
raconter l'armée des ondes le combat
entre les radios de la liberté les
radios alliés et les radios de la
collaboration pendant la dernière guerre
et va se poser la question finalement en
perd de guerre les mots sont-ils aussi
importants que les armes et les micros
que les canons oui ça c'est une citation
de MCF d'Hitler mais alors pour une fois
à la télévision nous allons entendre des
sons oui ce soir nous allons donc
entendre les émissions que les Français
entendaient sur leur poste aussi bien
les émissions qui venaient de Londres de
l'autre côté de la Manche que les
émissions de radio Paris qui étaient
sous contrôle allemand ou de radio Vichy
radio Paris radio Paris est allemand oui
puis nous allons voir aussi grâce à un
film inédit les visage de ceux qui
parlaient à Londres au français ici
Londres les Français parlent au français
et là on va voir Maurice Schuman et les
autres parler au français et puis les
téléspectateurs connaissent bien
maintenant le principe de cette émission
chaque semaine un historien nous
accompagne et sans mauvais jeu de mot
décodes pour nous les images et là il
s'agit de Jean-Noël Janet voilà alors
c'est un spécialiste à un triple titre
il a été ministre de la Communication il
a été le PDG de Radio France mais
surtout et avant tout pour nous c'est un
historien de la radio un historien des
médias et c'est grâce à lui ont préparé
cette
[Musique]
émission Jean-Noël Jeannet bonsoir cet
immense radio qu'on vient de voir a été
érigé sur la place de la Concorde pour
le 50e anniversaire de l'Appel des 18
juin je crois que à cette occasion on a
vraiment vu à quel point la radio tenait
une importance une grande importance
dans la mémoire collective des Français
ah oui c'était une initiative
remarquable qui était très remarquée
j'ai été frappé comme beaucoup de voir à
quel point tous les gens de la
génération qui av av vécu la guerre ont
été sensibl à ce qui avait été fait ce
jour-là et je crois que c'est parce que
ça évoquait dans leur souvenir quelque
chose de fort interrogez-les sur la
mémoire de la deuxème guerre mondiale
très souvent ils se référeront au
souvenir de de de ce qui leur est arrivé
par les ondes et cela je crois mérite
d'être d'être dit rappelé et il va
donner du du tonus à notre sujet voilà
on voit bien que donc la radio est au
cœur de la guerre au cœur du sujet et on
va remonter tout suite dans les années
30 pour voir comment très vite par les
hitlerriens la radio a é utilisée dans
la
propagande
avec les années 30 la radio s'installe
comme un média de masse consécration
suprême Marconi l'inventeur de la radio
reçoit la bénédiction papale à côté des
radios d'État les radios privées se
développent sur les omes de Radio Cité
c'est le triomphe des radio
crochet grand
[Musique]
je c je crois devoir vous donner un
conseil il faut prendre des
de Berlin l'exposition de la radiophonie
allemande inauguré par les ministresing
et l'objet de toute la sollicitude du
gouvernement national socialist les
nazis ont compris tout le parti qu'il
peuvent tier de la
radio poste à bon marché surnommé les
museaux
[Applaudissements]
d'Hitler
es
[Musique]
ma
es
bb n'hésite pas à affirmer que grâce à
la radio le régime a supprimé tout
esprit de
révolte le 25 juillet 34 les nazis
lancent un coup de force sur Vienne ils
assassinent le chancelier autrichien
dolphus qui s'oppose à eux et
investissent pendant quelques heures la
radio le coup d'État échoue mais ce
n'est que partie remise en septembre 38
la vermart entre en Autriche Vienne est
coupé du monde un reporter de Radio Cité
réussit pourtant à téléphoner il est
entré dans un bistr il y avait une
cabine téléphonique au fond il a dit
voulez-vous me passer Paris tel numéro
on lui a dit bien monsieur il a
attteendu 5 minutes et il a eu Paris il
a eu le studio de radio cité et à ce
moment-là il nous a dit je suis dans
Vienne je suis dans un café les
Allemands vont entrer d'une minute à
l'autre attendez dit-il et puis on a
attendu une minute il a pris le fil il
l'a raconté après ça il a tiré sur le
fil le plus possible il a gardé le
récepteur et nous a dit écoutez écoutez
le bruit des pas les Allemands en ce
moment
entrent dans Vienne puis ça a été coupé
mais nous étions peut-être cinq dans la
cabine on a senti que quelque chose se
passait dans le monde nous étions cinq
hommes à pleurer d'émotion c'était
fantastique parce que on s'est dit bah
voilà ça ça commence comme ça jeanel
jeanné est-ce que l'encadrement des
esprits par la radio nazie a été aussi
efficace que ne le dit gobels dans le
film qu'on vient de voir elle était
moins efficace il faut bien voir que
c'était l'intérêt de gobbeles de dire à
son maître Hitler que c'était essentiel
il est vrai aussi que dans toute
l'Europe on a eu tendance à surestimer
l'efficacité ce qui était un nouvel
instrument après tout la radio n'a joué
qu'un rôle tout à fait secondaire
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale un
roule militaire c'est dans oui c'est
dans les années 30 vraiment que elle
prend toute sa place et tout beau tout
neuf de telle sorte queon a tendance à
penser que on va réussir à à vraiment à
modeler les esprits et que ce sera
l'arme absolue songez que technique d'un
coup d'État le livre de malaparté qui
est 1931 est le premier à expliquer que
pour un apprenti dictateur l'essentiel
c'est d'aller se porter dans une ville à
la station de radio et que qui est le
maître de la radio est le maître des
esprits et des cœurs c'est ajouté
j'ajouterai que il y a une illusion
d'immédiateté qui est très dans le petit
film que que nous venons de voir à
propos de l'entrée dans
Vienne vous êtes là donc c'est vrai
c'est l'illusion nous savons bien que
maintenant la vérité c'est plus
compliqué comme nous pouvons parler vrai
parce que nous pouvons parler immédiat
nous pourrons être plus efficace que
avec l'ensemble des écrits qui
traditionnellement jusque là servait la
propagande les nazis avaient bien lu mal
àarté puisque finalement quand ils
veulent faire le coup contre doolfous
tout de suite ils se précipitent le
premier objectif c'est sur la radio
c'est la première grande guerre des
ondes effectivement entre entre
l'Allemagne et l'Autriche dans les
années qui ont précédé l'anchelous le
rattachement par la force de l'Autriche
à l'Allemagne il y a eu une sorte de de
de dialogue d'injure de de grande
violence dans les propos de la
propagande entre d'un côté Berlin et de
l'autre et de l'autre Vienne il y a eu
d'autres cas dans les années 30 d'autres
guerres où la radio prend cette
importance elle est importante dans la
guerre d'Espagne en particulier elle est
très importante dans la guerre entre le
Japon et la Chine le Japon s'en servent
beaucoup il faut voir que naturellement
dans les pays totalitaires dès ce
moment-là il apparaît que la radio est
plus efficace que dans les pays où la
presse est libre par conséquent les
cearable aux yeux des dictateurs régimes
totalitaires c'est que la presse écrite
on a de la peine à l'empêcher de passer
les frontières mais on y arrive on peut
saisir des ballots tandis que les ondes
ça franchit tous les postes de douane et
par conséquent on a l'impression là
aussi d'une efficacité inédite gbel
faisait construire des posts de radio
qui qui permettaient pas d'écouter les
radios étrangères oui on d'inventer ça
du côté des radios commerciales dans les
années 70 c'était pour un motif beaucoup
plus spécifique en effet voilà al
symbole des symboles la deuxième guerre
mondiale la Grande Guerre de 3945
commence par une histoire de radio oui
c'est un épisode très symbolique très
représentatif et qui est assez largement
oublié il faut savoir que le 31 août
1939 c'est-à-dire la veille du jour où
les nazis ont envahi la Pologne les
services de propagande d'Hitler ont
envoyé un commando de SS déguisé en
polonais pour envahir une station de
radio allemande proche de la Pologne en
haut de Silésie à Gitz pour faire croire
que les méchants polonais allaient venir
s'emparer de cette radio et ils ont
laissé même le cadavre d'un malheureux
habillé en polonais soldat polonais sur
les sur les marches de cette radio telle
sorte que kbbeles Hitler Heidrich ont pu
dire regardez nous faisons que riposter
ça une des provocations les plus
frappante dans les mains du du nazisme
et je crois que ça méritait être rappelé
voilà et le lendemain la guerre enfin
quelques J la guerre est déclarée la
guerre commence le lendemain
l'allemagnev la polne la guerre est
déclarée et la guerre commence on va le
voir il trava du PCE il comm ma la folie
des
[Musique]
grandeur septembre 39 la guerre
l'écrivain Jean girudou est nommé
commissaire général à l'information
l'allemag
devant non plus une paix dont elle est
la maîtresse mais une guerre dont la
commande semble lui
échapper alors que la moindre parole du
président dalalladier ou de Monsieur
Chamberlin trouve une résonnance et une
signification la parole de Hitler semble
maintenant à ses concitoyens décevantes
à ses ennemis VI de
sang sur les ondes le style de ces
discours est aussi alambiqué que
l'analyse est fumeuse
quant au programme formé de musique
classique et de pièces de théâtre il ne
soulève pas l'enthousiasme chez les
soldats sur la ligne Magin on préfère
chevalier à racine on a MRE des croisons
às fentres des il TS musé chambouler les
champs élysé en maillotter de terre
batttu toutes les beautés de nos statue
plong dans le noir la ville
lumière paris sera toujours
Paris la plus
B les nazis avec une onte d'avance
produisent dès l'automne 39 à partir de
l'émetteur de Stuttgart des émissions en
langue française un journaliste
d'extrême droite Paul ferdonet adorateur
d'Hitler s'illustre par sa propagande
pro-allemande par les soldats anglais de
mourir pour leur roi et leur pays soit
remplacé par celui de mourir pour la
France ce dont les Français
se montreront très trich bien qu'un peu
berlé on ne sait encore si les Français
prêteront à leur tour le cherment de
mourir pour
l'angleterreut Pasut pas
franc écou les racontard du [__] de
stutgard pas faut pas
franc te
laisser la presse prête à Paul ferlu
considérable qui alimente le myth de la
5è colonne celle des traîtres infiltrés
ce qui provoque un climat de suspicion
généralisé mesdames messieurs vous allez
entendre monsieur Paul Ren président du
Conseil l'objectif est rester le même
vaincre
l'ennemi l' que nous vivons est
[Applaudissements]
décisive le di la guerre cesse d'être
drôle au fur et à mesure de son
offensive la verm utilise les émetteurs
capturés comme celui de lîle qui
diffusent en français la liste des
prisonniers le FAM entendent en même
temps les communi de victoire allemand
qui en pleine débacle ajoute au
désarrois 7 millions de Français sont
sur les routes la radio est le seul
moyen d'information où alterne parole de
réconfort ou rodomontade il y a quelques
jours je visitais dans nos hôpitaux des
blessés et malad français revenus de
dunkerk tout me répondez presque gement
par une courte phrase ça va je
crois de tout cœur qu'après les mauvais
jours un temps viendra où nos deux
peuples pourront eux aussi se dire l'un
à l'autre maintenant ça
va la situation est grave
elle n'est nullement
désespérée voici les décisions que je
viens de prendre
le vainqueur de
Verdin le maréchal
Pétin désormais à mes côtés comme
ministre d'État mant toute sa sagesse et
toute sa force au service du pays il y
restera jusqu'à la
victoire j'ai demandé à nos adversaires
de mettre fin aux
hostilité le gouvernement a désigné hier
les PL potenties de recueillir leurs
conditions j'ai pris cette décision dure
au cœur d'un soldat parce que la
situation militaire
l'impos une des clauses de l'armistice
prévoit qu'aucune radio de langue
française n'émettra plus jusqu'à nouvel
ordre Radio Cité se saborde pour que ces
installations ne tombent aux mains de
l'occupant entré dans
Paris le 18 juin un général de brigade à
peu près inconnu lance sur les ondes de
la Bible ici un appel qui ne sera pas
enregistré quelques jours plus tard le
général de Gaulle réitère son appel à la
résistance j'invite tous les Français
qui veulent rester libr à m'écouter et à
me
suivre vive la France libre dans
l'honneur et dans
l'indépendance de Londres sur les ondes
de la BBC viendront désormais les
paroles de
liberté Britain would fight on alone
whatever they did their general told
their Prime Minister and he divided
cabinet in three
weeks England will have our neck rung
like a
chicken some
chicken
ne jeanel jeanné pendant la drôle de
guerre la presse de l'époque a attribu
une importance considérable à ce Paul
ferdonet ce journaliste qui était
d'extrême droite et qui parlait ou qui
parlait pas d'ailleurs au micro de Radio
Stuttgart al est-ce que ça pe êt un des
grands mythes de cette drôle de guerre
si c'est un mythe mais un mythe
révélateur effectivement il semble bien
les travaux de l'excellent historien qui
est Jean-Louis crémubac l'ont très bien
montré pour la première fois que
ferdonet est un peu une création du
deuxè bureau en fait c'est un personnage
tout à fait inconsistant et qui semble
en fait n'avoir jamais parlé de la radio
de stutgart l'idée était de d'émouvoir
les Français le deuxème bureau français
avec l'idée de de mettre en garde les
Français et les françaises contre les
effets néfastes de la propagande ça
s'est retourné contre les auteurs de
cette idée bizarre car du coup l'opinion
a eu tendance à en faire un personnage
maléfique d'une influence extraordinaire
et et on a même créé l'expression
ferdonisé je crois que c'est le CAN
enchaîné ou donc au-delà de cet épisode
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
qu'en temps de guerre la radio a
toujours avec la rumeur des relations
tout à fait particulières elle s'y prête
très bien fa on l'écrit on peut relire
la radio ça passe on dit qu'on a entendu
quelqu'un qui a dit que et donc dans
cette ce genre de guerre qui est
toujours extrêmement favorable au
développement des des rumeurs des bruit
des des canards des la radio en fait
sert à cela s'en nourrit et et sa
puissance supposée est elle-même grandit
par par par le souffle de cette rumeur
même c'est une sorte de dialectique très
curieuse alors il y a un autre fait qui
est peu connu je crois c'est quand
l'armée allemande attaque c'est
l'utilisation par par la vermart des
émetteurs qu'elle récupèreent et la
propagande qu'elle fait en français
vis-à-vis de la population française on
a l'impression à un moment que les
Français entendent le les nouvelles par
les Allemands est-ce que c'est vrai
est-ce que ça a été efficace al c'est
vrai que gobbeles a systématiquement
utilisé les grands émetteurs des régions
qu'il avait conquise il verersou
Bruxelles Lille et cetera Luxembourg
mais pendant la
période ement on a pas de sondage donc
c'est difficile de savoir mais il semble
bien que tant que la guerre était en
cours c'està-dire avant l'armistice les
effets de cette propagande ont été
relativement limité elle avait un double
but il s'agissait d'abord de de
démoraliser à l'arrière des lignes il
s'agissait ensuite de préparer les
esprits en France à une capitulation
ultérieure il semble pas que c'est joué
un rôle essentiel dans le magma des des
bruits et des revanche qui a compté
beaucoup bien sûr pendant l'exode c'est
l'utilisation par les gouvernants
français de la radio de parce là c'est
le seul moyen d'information il y a plus
accès bouleverant il n y a plus accès
pratiquement à la presse écrite ou alors
des journaux locaux qui sont eu même
plus ou moins désorganisés donc deux
fois par jour à midi et le soir les
Français et les Françaises qui sont
jetés sur la route de l'Exode cherchent
un poste de radio pour se tenir au
courant dans tous les récits de l'Exode
vous êtes frappé par l'importance de ces
deux rendez-vous et c'est là qu'on
entend Paul Renault c'est là qu'on
entend effectivement on peut vraiment
dire qu'à ce moment-là des millions de
Français la France entière vit au rythme
de de de la radio des émissions des
informations on peut en effet le dire je
crois que d'ailleurs quand vous
interrogez le contemporain il est clair
que dans leur mémoire c'est cette
période est attachée à des sou chacun se
rappelle ceux qui ont écouté 18 juin par
exemple l'appelle du général de Gaulle
moins nombreux qu'on a dit
ensuitepp se rappelle je vous devance se
rappelle presque toujours le décor où
ils l'ont entendu les circonstances où
ils l'ont entendu de même pour les
disccours de Pétin du 17 juin vous savez
je vous dis le cœur serré c'est le cœur
serré que je vous dis qu'il faut cesser
le combat ce discours quelle influence
il a eu al considérable bien sûr
d'autant plus que Pétin n'avait pas dit
dit il faut tenter de cesser le combat
il faut cesser le combat ce qui a
évidemment démoralisé les troupes
françaises qui de façon encore
sporadique se battait souvent très
vaillamment il faut cesser le combat on
a essayé de corriger é plus fort on a
essayé de corriger ensuite en rajoutant
il faut tenter de de C le combat mais le
mal était fait et d'une certaine façon
c'est là que que bascule la guerre dans
ce dialogue du 17 juin il faut cesser le
combat et du 18 juin il faut le
continuer il faut le continuer toute la
guerre qui commence se trouve
magnifiquement ramassée oui mais quand
même on peut dire qu'il y a des millions
de Français qui ont entendu l'appel
enfin l'appel le discours du 17 juin du
maréchal Pétin très peu ont entendu
l'appel du 18 juin oui mais très vite la
rumeur l' encore accouru que ce général
étrange avait appelé de Londres et par
conséquent le 19 le 20 puisqu'il parlait
à ceà tous les jours à la radio de
Londres de plus en plus nombreux sont
ceux qui se sont portés à l'écoute et de
proche en proche la chose s'est su avec
un éclat dont vous savez l'importance
historique voilà alors malheureusement
il n'est pour l'histoire il y a aucune
trace de ce discours du 18 juin
ENR prodeur demandé au général de GA de
le rejouer bien
lesette
ID les radios dans la guerre grand Radi
BBC Radio Paris et radio nationale radio
Vich
Mo dans cette V
de nous continuons à lutter de pied ferm
pour amener ainsi le triomp de la cause
qui nous a fait ensemble tirer les pai
allons bonne nuit dormez bien remble vos
forces pour car
viendra 1940 Paris est allemand et la
radio également radio Paris qui à partir
de juillet est sous ô direct de
l'occupant tandis qu'avichi la radio
nationale à longueur d'antenne tre des
couronnes au maréchal je veux leur dire
nous qui voyons à chaque instant Pétin
le chef légitime de tous les Français
nous l'aimons nous l'admirons et nous
savons qu'il sauvera la patrie hier je
le regardais pour sortir de son cabinet
de travail alors qu'il allait prendre un
peu d'air et de soleil sur les qu de
l'Allier où son passage suscite toujours
cette émotion vous savez qui fait monter
les larmes mes chers amis France célèbre
dans l'épreuve et la tristesse un Noël
de guerre écoutez un homme qui n'est là
que pour vous et qui vous aime comme un
père Noël d'une France
malheureuse Noël des séparé mais Noël de
toujours Noël d'espérance noël noël noël
noël à Paris on affiche la couleur sans
nuance les hordes bolcheviques sont
maintenus à l'est les brèches ont été
colmatées à l'ouest le R de l'Atlantique
est là garant de la sécurité de
[Musique]
l'EUR entre deux vociférations des
ultras de la collaboration les
programmes alignent le tout Paris du
spectacle le magazine de radio Paris les
ondes présent des artistes de renom qui
se partagent le micro avec de ténors en
chemise brune fort en alè Philipp et
jeanold
[Musique]
de ne fait en somme que confirmer
l'opinion générale lorsqu'elle assure
que l'Angleterre comme Carthage sera
exactement
détruite vous allez entendre Monsieur
Philippe enriot vous n'avez donc pas
compris que cette radio anglaise en
français c'est une entreprise montée par
des fripouilles à l'usage des imbéciles
de l'autre côté de la Manche la réplique
est vite trouvée Radio
parisonde Radio parisonde
radio Paris est allemand radio
Paris radio
Paris radio Paris est allemand à Londres
la BBC met sur pied dès juillet 40 une
émission quotidienne d'une demi-heure
diffusé chaque soir à 8h15 les Français
parlent au français où se distinguent
Jacques duchenè Jean
auberlet ici Londres les Français
parlent au français Jacques duchen
aujourd'hui
929e jour de la lutte du peuple français
pour sa
libération le patron tout à coup dit à
très haute voix en appuyant sur sa barre
quand on pense qu'un jour on ira comme
ça et puis ça sera pour de bon pour le
débarquement à cette idée ses yeux
rougis par la veille et par le sel lanc
un regard rempli de bonheur et c'est
pourtant vrai un jour on ira comme ça et
ce sera pour de bon au revoir mes amis
voici maintenant notre courrier de
France qui vous est présenté comme tous
les vendredis par Jacques Borel en outre
chaque soir pendant 5 minutes la France
Libre a son émission honneur et patrie
où s'illustre Maurice Schuman en 4 ans
il parlera plus de 1000 fois le
porte-parole de la France combattante
vous parle qu'il nous soit permis de
vous crier plus fort que jamais
l'espérance doit l'emporter sur
l'impatience et la certitude prévaloir
sur la douleur difficile d'apprécier
dans ces deux premières années de guerre
l'impact de la BBC le 1er janvier 41 deg
lance la consigne de déserter les rues
pendant 1 heure le mot d'ordre est peu
suivi sauf en Bretagne mais
l'interdiction par les autorités
allemandes d'écouter la BBC montre
qu'elle craignent les voix d'outremche
lorsque radio Paris répond en rime à la
BBC la preuve est faite de l'audience
des Français de Londres au jardin
d'Angleterre les sont fleur tous les
menteurs du monde
parle à la BBC au gré de ses ondes qu'il
fait bon fait bon fait bon au gré de ses
ondes qu'il fait bon
mentir il court il court le Laval il
voyage pour l'ennemi il a passer par
Paris prendre le mot d'ordre des nazis
le vla qui retourne à Vichy puis il
repart pour Paris Il court il court le
Laval en chemin de fer et en auto mais
tout ça va finir mal et espons que ça
sera
bientôt Jean Jan c'est quand même très
très émouvant d'entendre Churchill
parler en français et dire dormez bien
mais l'aubre revendra un jour oui c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire l'histoire de
la radio parce que la radio dans ses
Archiv nous fournit une sorte de
fraîcheur dans l'évocation des moments
qui parfois s'est échappé des pages de
l'écrit on voit bien dans ce film que
pour de Gaulle pour la France Libre la
radio devient très très vite un
instrument absolument capital on peut
pas faites faites l'exercice inverse
tâchez d'imaginer de Gaulle et gaulisme
sans radio ça paraît tout à fait
impossible naturellement il y a eu le
rôle d'information sur l'existence du
mouvement sur ses intentions sur
l'évolution de la politique c'est
essentiel mais c'est davantage certaine
façon la radio du général micro puisque
c'est comme ça souvent qu'on appelle deg
à ce moment-là la radio elle lui permet
de per les inconvénients de son exil de
son immigration de répondre à ceux qui
disent vous avez emporté la patrie à la
de vos souliers il répondent non vous
savez comme ctorius dans Corneille Rome
n'est plus dans Rome elle est tout où je
suis la France est ou de Gaulle et il
peut l'affirmer parce que de là où il
est c'est-à-dire de Londres il peut
grâce aux MICR grâce aux ondes parler à
la France entière et cela est essentiel
d' certaine façon on peut dire que la
France libre s'est inventée en cours de
route aussi par la radio elle s'est
donné à elle-même sa sa constitution sa
structure la parole n'est pas seulement
à la radio une traduction de ce qu'est
la France Libre est aussi une façon de
l'aider à se définir comme elle est en
terme historique comme efficace comme
essentielle comme symboliquement et
pratiquement décisive et qu'est-ce
qu'elle apporte aux Français les les
Français qui de plus en plus nombreux
vont écouter cette radio ça cristallise
l'esprit de la résistance ça montre
qu'elle existe c'est le premier degré au
fond de la résistance que d'écouter la
radio puisque c'est interdit puisque
tous les régimes totalitaires ont
toujours eu la tentation de confisquer
les postes de radio ça a été vrai en
Russie ça a été vrai en Allemagne ça a
été vrai dans les départements côtiers
sous l'occupation allemande c'est bien
parce qu'on a le sentiment que la radio
est dangereuse puisqu'elle est une
fenêtre vers la liberté et beaucoup de
témoignages de l'époque montrent comment
le simple fait de se mettîre à l'écoute
de la BBC est déjà un début c'est pas le
plus grand courage mais un début
d'adhésion à l'acte de résistance et par
là c'est historiquement fondamental il y
a plus ACI peut-être parce que la radio
de Londres la BBC et les émissions qui
sont faites en français apporte des
nouvelles et souvent des nouvelles qui
qui qui sont la vérité oui alors ça
c'est un choix c'est très intéressant de
voir en effet qu'il y a deux écoles il y
a l'école des des pays totalitaires et
l'école des démocraties du côté des pays
totalitaire c'est clair mentez mentez
mentez il en restera toujours quelque
chose et la petite
disciple sordide de Hitler qui est radio
Paris pratique exactement
cela en face il y a les démocraties qui
ont confiance dans les vertus de la
vérité très clairement la BBC a souhaité
pas dis pendant tout le début de la
guerre c'est quand même plutôt des
mauvaises nouvelles tant en anglais
qu'en français en français les du chè et
les autres ils nont pas caché les
mauvaises nouvelles Moscou sur le point
de tomber Singapour prise les mauvais
moments de la guerre sont dit et du coup
naturellement et c'était le même choix
qui été le choix de de Roosevelt qui
avant l'entrée des Américains dans la
guerre ne s'occupait pas directement
d'une radio nationale il utilisait les
radios commerciales pour s causeré au
coin du feu mais dès que la guerre a
éclaté alors on fait aux États-Unis avec
l'efficacité rapide qu'on connaît en
tempant de guerre aux Américains on fait
de la radio un instrument et on choisit
de le faire de le prendre comme un
instrument de vérité au total finalement
je crois que c'est la vérité qui a gagné
tant mieux alors est-ce que question
évidemment qui écoutit est-ce qu'on peut
mesurer l'influence l'audience en 41 42
de la radio de Londres par exemple quand
de Gaulle donne sa consigne des des v la
campagne des v C'est suivi c'est écouté
naturellement on n pas les moyens
médiamétrique d'aujourd'hui de savoir
qui écout il y a pas d' il s'en
féliciter je vous en laiss juge mais ce
qui est clair c'est qu'on a des signes
d'abord il y a un courrier très abondant
qui réussi à passer la censure postale
et arrivver à Londres et puis en effet
de temps en temps il y a une campagne de
ce type de Gaulle où les siens disent au
français par exemple à telle date de
telle heure à telle heure vous ne
sortirez pas dans les rues vous ferez
ville morte ça a marché d'une certaine
façon notamment du côté de la Bretagne
je crois que vous l'évoquez dans le film
voilà d'autre part effectivement la
campagne DV a fonctionné c'est une idée
qui est venu en parti de Belgique vous
aviez déjà entendu les collaborateurs
notoir par jeanérold paquil on entend
dans sa célèbre formule l'Angleterre
comme Carthage sera détruite c'est assez
saisissant quand oui ça supposait
d'ailleurs une bonne culture classique
de la part des auditeurs mais c'est très
saisissantio on l'avait plus souvent
entendu et on avait plus se rendre
compte effectivement d'une certaine
efficacité de cette redoutable éloquence
alors on va voir qu'à partir de 42 c'est
une véritable guerre qui se déroule dans
les ondes sur trois thèmes essentiel son
une campagne d'opinion entre la BBC les
Français de Londres et et radio Paris
sur le bombardements sur le thème du
travail en Allemagne et sur le thème de
la résistance et des maquill la radio
devient encore plus à ce momentl une
arme de guerre au sens propre
[Applaudissements]
exactement il ne faut pas désespérer on
les aura il ne faut pas vous arrêter de
résister n'oubliez pas la lettre V évez
[Musique]
chant
ici Londres les Français parlent au
français patience vous
arrivons Léonie nous allons retrouver no
BIF
fr ici l're à
notre émission est
terminée tout seu non votre Mar avec
vous non j'étais toute seule avec mon
gosse on allait se coucher petit qui est
là quel ge as
an tu as peur non trop bien ça
décourag monsieur Philippe Enot vous
parle dans la nuit dans la lumière grise
de désespoir dans le plein jour qui rend
plus bouleversante encore spectacle
d'horreur je nai pas besoin qu'on me
dicte les mots déchirants qui me
viennent au l'è et songeant à ceux qui
se sont laissés si longtemps abuser aux
Français qui accepteent d'un cœur léger
la destruction de votre pays et les
déchirements de la guerre civile
attendez encore un peu il vous faudra
sans doute demain plus de voiles de
deuil que de drapeau et plus de fleurs
pour les tombes que de bouquets pour les
vainqueurs
les habitants de Calais les habitants de
Boulogne surmer ceux dure ou de Brest
ceux de saint-nazer ou de l'Orient ceux
d'autres villes de France encore
m'écoute en ce moment ils ont tous payé
le tribu du sang à cette nouvelle forme
de guerre dans laquelle la France se
trouve prise dans cette accumulation de
souffrance il faut que nous continuions
à voir clair il ne faut pas que les
sentiments les plus légitimes
obscurcissent pour nous le but
final début 42 1600000 français sont
prisonniers en Allemagne radio Paris
crée une émission à leur intention allô
le stalac la France te
parle mon petit jeanud mon petit
Jean-Pierre si tu es là-bas à l'écoute
sois courageux mon petit gars sois bien
vaillant comme tu l'es j'espère que le
grand terir les vignes la culture la
charue te font beaucoup de bien
reviens-nous bien
gaillard l'Allemagne a besoin de main
d'œuvre lav propose échanger des
travailleurs français contre des
prisonniers c'est la
relève la Val ministres nommés par les
Allemands pour faire leurs affaires et
la traite des blancs pour faire leurs
affaires et la traite des blancs il veut
tous qu'on s'en aille là-bas chez les
Allemands en Allemagne ne va pas en
Allemagne les Français demeurent assez
obstinément ancrés dans leur mauvaise
foi pour aller demander au menteurs
salariés des radios anglo-américaines ce
qu'il refuse de demander au paysans qui
rentre de captivité ou à l'ouvrier qui
revient des usines
allemandes pendant que les captifs
d'hier bénissent le nom du président
Laval les Juifs de Londres ou de New
York le couvrent à leur radio d'un jur
et d'in famamille malgré le Zè de Laval
les volontaires ne se bousculent pas
pour aller travailler en Allemagne le 16
février 43 ont crée le S service du
travail obligatoire comme son nom
l'indique il ne s'agit plus de
volontaire il en est jusqu'à ce jour il
se sont dérobés à leur devoir il en est
d'autres qui sont tentés d'imiter leur
exemple et des mesures rigoureuses
seront prises même contre leur famille
ou des tiers ils se sont enfuis dans la
nuit pour ne pas aller en Allemagne et
pour mieux servir le pays ils ont pris
le
Maqui la résistance organise les
réfractaires au esto qui viennent
gonfler les maquis par ses slogans et
ses chansons la BBC indique le chemin de
la révolte ce sont ceux du Maqui
combattant pour la France bravant le
froid bravant la fin défiant l'horrible
esclavage bonneur et
patri allô
allô maqu de la haute
savoi la mobilité dans les maquis est un
élément essentiel de la lutte
ici le 6e bulletin d'information de la
BBC veuillez tout d'abord écouter
quelques messages
personnels la fortune vient en
dormant heureux qui commuliste a fait un
long
voyage nous nationalistes nous disons
aux Français qui ne sont et ne veulent
être ni allemands ni anglais ni
américains ni Russ ni vaincu ni idiot
nous disons que la guerre commence
aujourd'hui contre l'ennemi du dedans et
qu'elle se fera en armes compte à compte
avec ceux de
la de torence ha savoix que je vous
parle ce matin les camions embarqu par
fourn les fameux
résistants je les ai vu français et
étrangers armée secrète et FTP confondu
je les ai vu arriv sans armes car le
trait dominant de cette capitulation
c'est que tous ces hommes ont été lâchés
par leur chef au premier assaut mené
contre eux et que même ont lâché leurs
armes pour fuir plus vite la silhouette
d'un oiseau de malheur une poubelle à la
place du cœur l'air d'un Macabé amateur
et d'un
arsouille la bouche en forme d'on noir
de plat comme écoutoir il n'est pas très
joli à voir en Rio la
trouilleor jeanel Jan on voit quand même
un phénomène amusant c'est que les deux
radios qui s'opposent utilisent la
chanson la chansonnette pour faire de la
politique oui l'esprit chanonier était
déjà très présent à la radio avant la
guerre et il est là mais mais au-delà je
dirais qu'il faut être très attentif à
ce qu'on va appeler le le le N politique
de la politique c'estd l'usage qui est
fait par les deux radios en face de de
toutes sortes de de types de de radio
qu'on invente d'émissions qui permettent
de parler des choses graves sous un mode
sur un mode badin là on a l'impression
que il y a que des éditoriax politiques
que des discours en fait il y a des
programmes qui sont pas du tout
politiques qui passent vous avez bien
fait de de restituer ces ces refrains
car dans la mémoire des contemporains
aussi ils ont une grande place alors
quelle est l'efficacité des des
consignes ou des des mots d'ordre que
donne la radio de Londres par exemple le
refus du STO est-ce qu'on peut mesurer
si c'est suivi si la radio à ce
moment-là joue vraiment un rôle
déterminant tous les témoignages
montrent qu'en effet la radio a joué à
cet égard par les mots d'ordre qu'elle
transmettait un rôle essentiel dans la
prise de conscience de la possibilité de
refuser le STO le service du travail
obligatoire et par conséquent dans la
constitution des Maqui dans la deuxième
partie de la guerre la radio n'est plus
seulement une source d'information il
est plus seulement une occasion de de
rassemblement un symbole d'unité un
début de résistance elle devient
vraiment puissamment un instrument pour
euh résister au sens propre c'est-à-dire
pour pour lutter contre contre l'ennemi
pour prendre le maquip pour pour en
attendant la en attendant les sabotages
sabot 43 44 que la radio devient un
acteur direct que donne les consignes
donne les messages messages bien sûr
tout l'ensemble des messages cryptés que
nous connaissons tous donc c'est une
nouvelle fonction qui se précise à
mesure que la guerre avance et puis
alors il y a un personnage qui émerge
vraiment c'est Philippe enriot qui
doncon a entendu encore là et qui
devient euh la voix vraiment de la
collaboration et puis une voix qui est
tellement importante que on se répond de
radio à Radio et Schuman répond à enryot
et ma Schuman a été une grande voix et
et ce dialogue en effet à un moment
donné a incarné de vision de la France
d'une façon tout à fait tout à fait
frappante et c'est parce que hryou était
incontestablement efficace dans son
éloquence particulière qu'on l'a tué on
va le voir maintenant d'ailleurs c'est
le débarquement et la mort de Philippe
enriot nous sommes menac c'est encore
une invasion de la France qu'est-ce qui
se passera à ce momentl c'est encore un
sujet d'inquiétude et en point
d'interrogation qu'on se pose combien de
temps tout cela va-t-il
durer si semaines après cet étonnant
discours le 5 juin 44 à 21h15 200
messages sont lancés sur les omes de la
BBC ils indiquent au responsable des
réseaux de résistance que le jour J est
arriv ici lres les forces navales
alliées avec le soutien de puissantes
formations aériennes ont commencé ce
matin le débarquement des armées allié
sur les côtes nord de la France la
progression des alliés accélère la
décomposition de la collaboration mais
derrière son micro Philippe enriot
imperturbable continue quand on regarde
les premières photos des villes
normandes et qu'on voit ce qui en reste
on se demande si les histoires du
Conquérent de Bailleux et ses
processions triomphales dans les ru
encombré d'une foule qui lui jette des
fleurs et brand des drapeaux n'ont pas
été inventé à l'usage d'un peuple de
gâte
ça lesaborurs
àanterne
lesabor le 28 juin 44 un commando de la
résistance déguisé en milicien l'exécute
vous êtes venu comme tous les jours à la
même heure
pour entendre la voix de Philippe enriot
vous l'entendrez plus il a été abattu à
coup de
revolv sous les yeux mêmes de sa
femme je ne répondrai plus s'il y a du S
entre nous c'est vous qui l'avez versé
je vous ai fait trop de ne mais je vous
méprise trop pour avoir encore quelque
chose à vous dire août 44 c'est
l'insurrection de Paris en pleine
bataille Jean guignnebert et Pierre
Cheffer réussissent à émettre d'un
studio rue de l'Université pour la
première fois depuis 4 ans la voix de la
France Libre vient de France mes chers
amis il y a 4 ans il y a plus de 4 ans
que je suis venu pour la dernière fois
devant le microphone vous mesurez j'en
suis sûr l'immense joie que j'éprouve à
vous retrouver tous je sais avec quelle
colère vous avez entendu des hommes
traîtres à leur patrie se faire les
porte-paroles serviles de la propagande
h Ren ces hommes ont pris la fuite ils
sont partis dans les fourgons de
l'ennemi mais nous les retrouverons nous
les jugerons et nous les châtirons pour
leur
crime par j' avis l' que c'éta des
blindésems la ch tellement belle encore
que je pvais l'imaginer mais non cétait
de Blind de la division lecl avantarde
de l'É de la
Libération le général le est mainant
rentré à la préfecture généraland que
mot pour la radio la nation française
non ça ser oui ça ça exprimera trop mal
les sentiments donc c'est quand je
préfère pas je va demander aux Parisiens
de vous parler eux-mêmees et vous dire
ce qu'ils en pensent bravo ok oh nous
sommes tellement contents Happ monsieur
dit-nous quelque chose je suis très
émotionné de voir tout cette belle armée
qui nous fait rement notre joie à tous
et je crie vive la France et vive les au
cours de leur débat les Allemands
détruisent les émetteurs fin août 44 il
ne reste que 7 % du réseau national en
service la guerre n'est pas encore finie
mais déjà des chansons j'ai ché ma
voiture dans la nature en criant hi hi
pour l'armée leair je ch C plein
[Musique]
d'espoir ici
long les Français parlent au
français cette phrase que vous avez tant
entendu cette soirée passée vous
l'entendrez plus
elle disparaît comme d'autres phrases
ont
disparu chaque fois que au cours de la
glorieuse épreuve nous franchissions une
étap jeel Jean cette interviewfin cette
déclaration du Général Leclerc en pleine
libération de Paris c'est assz
extraordinaire comme document ce refus
du lirisme est un effet beaucoup plus
évocateur que beaucoup de de propos
cléronants et une fois de plus nous
redit à quel point la radio restitue un
instant avec une force qu'aucun autre
témoignage souvent ne possède alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe à la Libération
puisque la radio recommence il y a des
nouvelles équipes quel est l'héritage de
ces années de guerre finalement en
France l'héritage est important car les
dirigeants ont découvert l'importance du
du média neuf de la radio et même ils
ont tendance puisqu'ils ont gagné en
exagérer le poids de telle sorte que le
nouveau la Nouvelle République la 4e
République va d'emblé s'efforcer de
mettre la main sur ensemble du système
radiophonique avant la guerre dans les
années 20 et surtout dans les années 30
nous avions un double secteur un peu
comme aujourd'hui un secteur privé et un
secteur public avec les avantages je
crois de cette diversité à partir de 44
le gouvernement met pesamment la main
sur la radio et en dehors de Radio
Luxembourg de R 1 un peu plus tard
l'essentiel des ondes appartient à la
radio pourquo c'est un lien direct avec
la avec la guerre parce que l'efficacité
de la radio comme instrument guerrier
paraît à beaucoup pouvoir être transposé
euh en période de paix comme instrument
politique et alors c'est une tentation à
laquelle peu échappe les gouvernements
successifs euh tous les partis étaient
d'accord là-dessus ustracis non
naturellement quand ils étaient dans
l'opposition ils étaient contre quand ça
était la 4e République on donnait pas la
parole au général de Gaulle quand ça a
été la 5e République au moins jusqu' 65
les opposants euh à cette 5e étaient à
peu près laissés de côté il a fallu
attendre les années 80 pour qu'on en
revienne à une situation digne d'une
nation démocratique avancée alors pardon
la guerre froide a succédé à la guerre
chaude dans les années 50 c'était le
rapport Est-Ouest alors la guerre des
ondes a continué mais alors sous une
autre forme ça c'est le point de vue
international c'est vrai qu'elle a
continué c'est vrai qu'elle a joué un
rôle essentiel pendant toute cette
période d'affrontement entre les les
deux blocs et que il y a eu une escalade
du côté démocratique comme du côté
soviétique on a dépensé beaucoup
d'argent à la fois du point de vue du
glve et du point de vue du bouclier à la
pour émettre et pour se protéger pour
brouiller s' imaginez encore là que les
radios avaient une importance
considérable et qu'il fallait parler
elle elle a été importante cette radio
en particulier pour l'ensemble des pays
des démocrati populaire qui n'avait pas
accès à ce moment-là à d'autres sources
d'information que cette radio Voice of
America Radio Free Europe et ca on va
voir des on voit des image de
l'insurrection de 53 à Berlin mais en
même temps à Berlin et surtout à
l'occasion de Budapest la révolte de
Budapest qui avait été en partie suscité
par les les appels au refus du régime
communiste qui venait des radio
américaine cet événement qui a abouti à
ce que la révolte soit écrasée sans que
naturellement les alliés les pays
occidentaux viennent aider les les les
Insurgents cela a amené sûrement un
changement de ton dans les radios
internationales une fois de plus
d'ailleurs on retrouve le débat ça m'a
frappé quand j'étais en charge de Radio
France Internationale dans les années 80
de voir que il y avait deux doctrines
celle de la propagande une fois de plus
et celle de la vérité la France avait
choisi délibérément le camp de la vérité
persuadé qu'on parlait plus efficacement
lorsqu'on savait dans certains cas ne
pas taire ce qui n'allait pas est-ce
qu'il y a des secteurs dans le monde et
des régions où la radio joue encore ce
rôle d'armes de guerre aujourd'hui elle
joue elle peut le jouer dans ce qu'il y
a des des guerres des affrontements elle
le joue presque toujours lorsque un
système vient
pesamment s'affaer s'installer
elle le joue lorsque un système vient
pesamment interdire la liberté
d'expression et du même coup la radio
prend tout son tout son poids
politiqued aujourd'hui il y a la
télévision et la la guerre des images à
remplacé la guerre des on c'est ça qui
est très nouveau et très récent
jusqu'ici enfin pendant plusieurs
décennies seul les ondes les antennes la
radio permettaiit de passer les
frontières on pouvait voir les
télévisions libre lorsqu'on était dans
un pays opprimé que dans les régions
frontalières et encore de façon
difficile euh depuis les satellit
évidemment les choses ont changé et nous
savons que nous sommes à cet égard
n'abusons pas du mot mais il y a un peu
de vrai dans un village planétaire du
point de vue des médias mais ça c'est
une autre histoire une autre émission
peut-être journal jeunné à la fin de
cette émission on va regarder un certain
nombre de livres qui nous ont servis
pour préparer cette émission et pour les
chercheurs les étudiants les lycéens et
puis tous ceux que ça intéresse on va
donner un certain nombre d'indications
je commence par le livre que vous avez
consacré à George Mandel parce que
George Mandel a joué un rôle important
dans la radio oui George Mandel a été le
premier grand ministre de l'Information
ministre des PTT mais le grand ministre
de la radio et notamment c'esti qui a
pris des initiatives importantes pour é
mettre en N courte en direction des des
des du nazisme en direction du 3è Reich
il a fondé des émissions avec des gens
comme Pierre Berto coopo c'est un grand
un grand homme de la radio alors George
Mandel édition du seuil je rappelle vous
avez publié euh concordance des temps
l'actualité du passé aussi un micro vous
avez vu sur la couverture ben oui c'est
pour ça que je le montre euh donc et
dedans il y a un article sur staviskiy
et la radio le rôle de STAV de la radio
dans l'affaire staviskii une série de
réflexion en effet notamment à propos
des médias sur sur les rebonds de
l'actualité ce qui est répété ce qui est
différent c'est le travail même de
l'histoire voilà ce qui est frappant
c'est que sur l'émission qu'on a fait ce
qu'on a fait ce soir finalement il y a
peu de livres l'historiographie est en
retard encore en dépit de travaux
récents c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas
l'équivalent par exemple du grand livre
d'azabrigs sur la BBC en anglais
j'espère que la nouvelle génération de
chercheurs va aboutir à un résultat
semblable dans les années qui viennent
alors il y a cet ouvrage qui nous a
beaucoup servi la Guer des ondes c'est
l'histoire des radios de langue français
pendant la deuxème guerre mondiale et
c'est publié par la communauté des au
public de langue française je ne sais
pas je ne suis pas sûr qu'on le trouve
facilement dans le publque il a été
préparé par hen Eck en particulier et le
chapitre concernant la France et du à
l'enec et à Jean-Louis cré brac mais il
y a aussi des chapitres sur la Belgique
le Canada la Suisse qui nous évite
d'être trop galocentrique voilà c'est
peut-être l'ouvrage qui est le plus
utile pour suivre ce qu'on a vu ce soir
une iconographie importante aussi voilà
il y a cet ouvrage s'appelle aussi la
guerre des ondes parues chez plomb de
Jacques Parot de Gubel sakadfi vous
l'avez lu assz Ann oui je l'ai lu assez
anecdotiques mais enfin avec des
éléments d'in formation utile bon pour
ceux que ça intéresse et puis alors
l'ouvrage je crois que c'est le seul qui
existe sur une histoire de la radio la
télévision de Pierre Michel déjà un peu
ancien déjà un peu ancien mais utile
également utile comment votre avis
d'historien parce que il permet de
d'avoir une vision de l'ensemble du
sujet enfin il ne tient pas encore la
place que devrait avoir grande œuvre en
plusieurs volumes collectifes que d'un
jour au l'autre nous mettrons un
chantier ça va
venir sur l'an 40 alors là c'est pas
spécifiquement sur la radio sur la
guerre des ondes mais c'est un livre
absolument indispensable je crois
Jean-Louis créux Briac c'est un maître
livre je suis content de de l'honorer
aujourd'hui la guerre oui ou non c'est
le premier volume des des Français de
l'an 40 il y a deux volumes et notamment
il y a beaucoup de choses très neuves
sur la politique de l'information du
gouvernement d'aladier de la période de
la drôle de guerre c'est tout à fait
remarquable c'est paru chez galimar il y
a 3 ou 4 ans il y a certain nombre
d'ouvrages et je passe rapidement dessus
mais pour ceux que ça intéresst je
signale quand même qu'à la bibliothèque
d'histoire de nanter il y a les mémoires
de jean-hérold paquy qu'on a entendu
tout à l'heure la bdiic la bibliothèque
de documentation internationale quandtin
par oui absolument parole en l'air aussi
de Jean Hol pquy sont les discours qu'il
prononçait à Radio Paris et puis il y a
le recueil des éditoriax de Philippe
enryot qui l'a prononcé en 1944 le
Philippe enryot don on entendait la voix
tout à l'heure là on peut le retrouver
par l'écrit encore une fois pour ceux
que ça peut intéresser et puis enfin je
termine par là il y a euh ces cinq
volumes publiés par la Documentation
française ici Londres c'est également à
initiative de Jean-Louis réubriac quand
il était responsable de la Documentation
française et ce sont les textes en effet
des textes parmi d'autres é prononcés au
micro c'est très très important ça
permet d'aller au-delà de la simple
mémoire au-delà de ce qu'on répète
toujours et d'aller vraiment se Colter
avec la réalité de ce qui a été dit
pensé exprimé c'est c'est un instrument
de travail fondamental voilà on retrouve
tous les les les textes donc prononcés
au micro de Radio Londres pendant la
guerre certain d'entre eux ENF il y en a
plusieurs centaines je voudrais enfin
signaler si vous me le permettez les
cahiers les cahiers d'histoire de la
radiodiffusion qui sous une apparence
modeste sont une contribution très utile
à cette histoire c'est publié par le
Comité d'histoire de la radiodiffusion
et on peut se les procurer notamment à
Radio France voilà merci jeanel Jeannet
merci à
[Musique]
vous la Gard des onde vient de s'achev
Patrick et la semaine prochaine
changement de registre changement de
période puisque nous allons évoquer à
l'occasion du 70e anniversaire de sa
disparition le destin de linine destin
Postume oui il est possible peut-être
même probable qu'à l'occasion cette de
ce 70e anniversaire les autorités russes
enlèvent le corps de l'énine du mausolé
où il est donc depuis 70 ans et on en
profite nous dans les bruures de
l'histoire pour retracer effectivement
le rôle de Lénine dans les premières
années de la Révolution et sa
responsabilité dans la terreur alors on
va le faire avec un historien qui
s'appelle Nicolas vert qui a beaucoup
travaillé à Moscou depuis des années qui
par AR oui qui revient de Moscou qui
parle russe qui a travaillé sur les
archives russes et notamment les
archives de la Teka donc il y aura
beaucoup de choses à nous apprendre et
puis j'ajoute qu'il y a des documents
absolument étonnants des documents
formidables des charges de cavalerie
dans pendant la guerre civile qu'on va
voir dans cette émission des documents
très très beaux à la semaine prochaine
donc pour ce numéro sur
[Musique]
Lénine